susana es una ingeniera de software
quiere crear un dibujo a gran escala de
un procesador dentro de un teléfono
celular el procesador es un chip
cuadrado de 9 milímetros en cada lado
dibuja el procesador de tal forma que
una unidad en la cuadrícula de abajo
represente medio milímetro bueno vamos a
pensar en los dos mundos por un lado
tenemos el dibujo y por el otro tenemos
el chip del mundo real entonces para el
dibujo vamos a usar las unidades del
papel de graficar unidades y para el
chip vamos a pensar en milímetros
entonces aquí tenemos nuestra tabla y
nos dicen que dibujemos el procesador de
tal forma que una unidad represente
medio milímetro entonces una unidad
representa medio milímetro y también nos
dicen que el procesador mide 9
milímetros de cada lado entonces cuántas
veces multiplicamos un medio para llegar
a 9 claro tenemos que multiplicar por 18
por lo tanto aquí vamos a multiplicar
por 18 ahora si queremos hacer el dibujo
a escala sabemos que es un chip cuadrado
y como la escala es que una unidad
representa medio milímetro 18 unidades
representan 9 milímetros
entonces dibujemos 18 unidades de un
lado 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15
6 17 18 este es el lado izquierdo del
chip y ahora dibujemos 18 unidades de
ancho que representan 9 milímetros en el
mundo real 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
14 15 16 17 18 ahí está y ahora
simplemente dibujamos lo demás y nos
queda así ahí lo tiene hemos hecho un
dibujo a escala de nuestro procesador
nos vemos en otro vídeo